Hello everyone. I hope that you had a
good. Look at this.
The dollar index is moving up, okay? And
now it's going back inside this zone
here, okay?
So, I mean, it's kind of confirming a
deviation, okay? We were talking about
the idea of a three-tops pattern here.
One,
two, three, with a potential deviation.
Also, this zone is exactly 100, so a
deviation below 100, so 99, as it did,
it would make a lot of sense because,
you know, we're talking about two
digits, not three. So, that's quite
psychological move, okay?
Cuz if the dollar index has been above
100 for quite some time, okay? For
literally, uh, 1 year. Uh, if it dips
now below 100, then, you know, it's
going to go in the headlines of all the
news. The dollar index has fallen below
100. It's now at 99, okay? So, then the
investors are going to go short.
Okay?
Uh, or they're going to sell their their
dollar. So, that's what we're talking
about the idea of a potential deviation
below 100. I think it's kind of
confirmed now.
Because if you go in lower time frame,
you can see here how they finished to
develop this W formation that we were
talking about. Now,
we had a potential resistance that was
the 4-hour 50 May. It smashed through,
okay? Then, retested the resistance,
this orange line that was the the
previous support. You know, you have a
little retrace, but then again, they
smashed it, okay? And now we are above
it. So, as long as the dollar index
holds above 100.50,
then, you know, it's prime,
you know, for a higher move. Where to?
Well, you have here a small gap in the
chart that probably is going to get
filled. Let me mark it for you, here,
okay? You got a little gap here.
Uh, 101.20,
okay? That gap is probably going to get
filled. Um, so, you know, as long as the
dollar index holds above here, I don't
tell you, I don't see the dollar index
going down again.
And I'm going to tell you why. Because
on Wednesday, next Wednesday, 26th of
July, we have the FOMC meeting,
and they are expecting to hike another
25 basis points, okay? Which is good for
the dollar index, okay?
So, that's what I'm telling you.
Um, I think that this pump
it's also in anticipation to that 25 uh,
basis point hike, okay? Uh, now thinking
that, you know, we have today it's
Friday, we have Monday, Tuesday, you
know, the days before uh, the FOMC
meeting on Wednesday, I expect that in
those days
the dollar index either holds here
or pumps higher, okay? I'm not expecting
the dollar index to go down because it
wouldn't make much sense, okay? At least
to my understanding. Now,
uh, thanks to this move to the dollar
index that we were expecting,
this W bottom, okay? And this potential
deviation, then there were some trades
that we were talking about. One of them
was euro versus the dollar, okay? You
got here, we were talking yesterday. No,
sorry, 2 days ago.
That this looked like a peak formation
here, okay? You also have these two
weeks at the highs.
Uh, the first week gets filled by the
second week, so, you know, perfect.
There is no imbalance at the highs. And
it seems like with these two weeks, they
were, you know, trapping breakout
traders that were thinking, "Okay, this
is resistance, so if price moves here,
I'm going to go long, okay?" So, I think
that they trapped those those traders.
Also, at the same time as anybody going
short here was going to place their stop
losses here, okay? So, that's, you know,
they get stopped and they don't price.
And uh, 2 days ago, I think we were
around this zone here, okay? And we were
saying that it's likely that it goes to
the 4-hour 50 MA. And now you can see
that it has gone
below it. Okay?
Um to be honest, to my understanding, it
still has quite a long way down. Okay?
Because you have here this liquidity
pool here, one more here, one more here,
and one more here. Okay? So, there are
still some imbalances in the chart, and
this could, you know, be quite a nice
Bart Simpson pattern.
Of course, this I'm not dismissing the
idea that I can go again, you know, it's
at 1.12. It can easily go to 1.09
in my opinion. Okay?
And that would be a nice
2% move. Okay? I don't know if you want
to see it some kind of retrace. It's
likely that we see some retrace. I'm
going to tell you why. I think we I
think that if we go to the dollar index,
sorry, if you go to the dollar index,
it's possible
that the DXY
tries to, you know, test this level as
support again.
Okay? So, during this dump here, during
this is more retrace, that's what you
could see maybe the dollar the euro
versus the dollar, you know, having a
little retrace, and that could give us a
better support entry. Okay?
Um so, that's what I'm thinking in the
chart there. You got the dollar index
and the euro versus the dollar. Now,
also, if you go and check the dollar
versus the Japanese yen,
okay?
You can see how it's pumping. Okay?
Because the dollar is pumping. So,
that's one of the things, but there is
something that we don't like much here.
Um I don't really like
this big liquidity pool that level here.
Okay? That would be an imbalance. So,
you know, if the dollar tries to retrace
that support level, the DXY, then it's
likely that this pair, the dollar versus
the Japanese yen, retraces this
liquidity pool, okay? And then it can
continue higher. And that's something
that I would like to see. Why? Because
if the dollar versus the Japanese yen
keeps going up and leaves this
imbalance behind, then it's going to
probably happen something similar
to what the euro versus the dollar
happened, okay? Peak formation and
possibly a Bart Simpson pattern to
retrace this liquidity pool over here,
okay? So, those are the two forex pairs
that I'm looking at at the moment.
Now,
thinking Let's talk again about the idea
that next Wednesday we have the FOMC
meeting and
you know, we're expecting another hike
of 25 basis points, okay? Basically
because the Fed has been saying so.
Also, in the economic projections in the
past FOMC meeting in the dot plot, they
said that it was possibly two more hikes
of 25 basis points, okay? So, based on
that
the economists and experts are expecting
another hike of 25 basis points on
Wednesday, okay? What does that mean?
That means that the two-year yield
Let me take you there, sorry. Uh
like this.
Okay? The two-year yield has been
rising for the past week in anticipation
to the next Wednesday, okay? To next
week. Because they're expecting that,
you know, with another hike, they should
continue going higher, okay? Now,
um I'll tell you something about this
chart.
Now, this chart, the two-year yield, is
pretty much positively correlated with
the interest rates, okay?
Uh you can see that the high the current
high is
um 5.12, okay? Uh this matches with the
5.10 median
uh
a projection in the dot plot that they
were talking the Fed for the interest
rate, okay? So, it matches, not the
problem
is that they've raised
that median, okay? And they're expecting
you know, more more hikes, so
you know, naturally, we should expect
the two-year yield to move higher, okay?
That's what I'm expecting. I'm expecting
this chart to go higher.
Okay? Maybe to 5.50.
Um when this chart goes up,
that is usually bad news for the S&P and
for Bitcoin, okay? Just the economy in
general. So, if we go now to the S&P,
let's check the futures, okay?
Uh we were talking about the idea
uh to be a second one we were going
through through this charts, okay? We
were talking about the idea that these
two zero lines are resistance, okay? And
how I'm trading this I is uh I'm waiting
for a deviation. Um if you check this
out, it seems that, you know, there
might be a little deviation here in
play. Okay? For now, it's kind of
recovering that level. Let's see how it
closes today, okay? This is a daily time
frame. But, if it closes again below
this zone here,
okay? Then, you could see here
a potential deviation consolidated on
the resistance. Here is where you can
short.
Okay?
To
um well, you have here some levels cuz
you have here some supports, but of
course, you do have this gap here at
4,300,
okay? Which I think that this gap is
going to get filled at some point.
That's what I think. So, you know, uh
stay tuned with this chart with S&P
because
I'm looking for a deviation either in
this zone here or if we can recover this
zone and push higher, then a deviation
in this zone uh 4,719,
okay? That's what I'm looking for at the
moment. Um I'm target, of course, this
gap here, this uh blue box in the chart.
But, with the idea that the 2-year yield
is going up,
then next week we're expecting another
hike of 25 basis points. That doesn't
leave the S&P in a good place. Of
course, it's going to depend on what
Jerome Powell says, the tone if he's
hawkish, dovish, what he this about the
next uh
if there is any new potential interest
rate hike in the future or not. That's
going to move the S&P also, okay? But
for now, that's what I'm telling you.
I'm looking for a top here. Okay? I know
that we are, you know, I think 4% away
from the previous high, uh 5% away, but
I'll tell you, I'm looking for a
deviation
either in this one here
or in this one here. So, let's see how
that plays out. Let's see if we can get
a chance of that trade, okay? More
things. Gold. What's gold doing? Let's
get that, okay?
Check out this.
We're going to the I'm not going to the
No, in the the daily time frame is fine,
yeah.
Let's go into the daily time frame.
Um I marked these levels for you, okay?
This is the level 2,000.
Okay? Although, well, to be honest,
since the main resistance is very high,
okay? And it's around 2,000 69. But
uh what I want to say is that it always
goes
above 2,000
when something bad is going on because,
you know, the investors, when they
invest in gold, it's because they want
to, you know, find safety. Okay? They
want to feel safe against the economic
problems, okay? That could be the
COVID-19. Look what happened during
COVID-19. They breached the 2,000 zone.
With the Russian invasion of Ukraine,
again, they went above 2,000. And now
with the banking crisis, again. Now,
what does this mean, okay? To me, this
means that
if we mark this high
Well, there you go. Something like this,
okay? 2,070.
You can see that there is it's test is
is a very strong resistance, okay? Three
times, three hits, okay? To the upside.
Now,
I feel that with all the recession thing
going on,
um
I'm feeling quite bullish in gold, to be
honest, okay? Uh I think that if there
is another attempt to the highs,
it's very likely that we break above
this level.
Then, if there is a retrace and this
level can hold,
you know, gold is set to go higher.
Um that's what I think, okay? I'm quite
bullish with gold, to be honest, for the
next, say,
uh 6 to 12 months, okay? I'm feeling
quite bullish with gold, to be honest.
Um so, that's one thing.
Um what else? Well, of course, let's go
to Bitcoin. Let's have a look at
Bitcoin, okay? With all these things
that I was talking about about the FOMC
next Wednesday, you can see that Bitcoin
is is still
inside of this range here,
okay? You can see it's, you know,
playing ping pong.
You had a deviation above the highs to
grab that liquidity pool, but we haven't
got so far a deviation or a breakout
below the lows, because that's something
that in a range there is always
liquidity at the highs that has been
taken here with this deviation, and of
course, liquidity at the lows. So,
I'm naturally expecting
that, you know, with the FOMC, with a
new hike of 25 basis points,
I'm favoring a breakout to the downside
of this, uh range, okay? Where to? Well,
you have here some kind of support upon
a potential support, because it hasn't
been tested yet, okay? You have here two
touches to this resistance, okay? Um
this is a level where we could find some
support in Bitcoin, okay? Now, if we go
into lower time frame in Bitcoin, okay?
For all those day traders that trade
Bitcoin, I just dropped my notebook.
Anyway, we go into the 15-minute time
frame,
and you can see, okay?
We've got here
a long in a big imbalance here, okay?
This liquidity pool over here. Can it
get retrace?
Likely, yeah. Okay. But, for that
what you need to see is Bitcoin getting
above this green line here. You can see
it's been resistance all this time.
Resistance here, okay? You got
deviation. Again, resistance, okay? So,
what you want is to see Bitcoin get
above this level, hold, and push higher
to recover this liquidity pool. Okay? In
yesterday's video, we were going through
the heat map to the liquidation heat
map, and there was still a lot of
liquidity
higher, okay? With higher, I don't mean
above 30 above 31,500, okay? But, I mean
all the way there. Why? Because also you
go here two imbalances, okay? These two
large red candles, okay? They can get
retraced, too. But,
in my opinion,
if they get retraced,
this would be before Wednesday,
okay? Because in Wednesday, the
narrative says that Bitcoin should go
down, okay? Let's see how that plays out
because you know that Bitcoin likes to
do the opposite, okay? But, naturally,
I'm expecting Bitcoin to go down. So,
if they want to retrace these two
liquidity pools here,
they should hurry up, okay?
Um
to be honest,
with the dollar going up, the only
chance for Bitcoin to break out to the
upside and start to, you know, retrace
these imbalances here,
okay? Is if the dollar index
retraces now,
or if the dollar index consolidates
here,
then a good chance for Bitcoin is over
the weekend.
Okay? And I know I always tell you over
the weekend nothing usually happens, but
uh this weekend, thinking that the
dollar index is, you know, looking quite
bullish, it's difficult to imagine that
Bitcoin can make a move to the upside
when the dollar index is looking like
that, okay? So, that's what I'm telling
you.
If you see today the dollar index not
dropping,
I think you're you're not going to see
Bitcoin going up. I might be wrong with
this one, okay? Because again Bitcoin
likes to do
different things.
But thinking about that way, do you know
that over the weekend
the stock market is closed, Forex is
closed, okay? That's when you could see
Bitcoin moving higher and you know,
retrace these imbalances here
before a dump probably next week, okay?
That's what I'm looking at at the
moment. So anyway, that's pretty much
everything.
Uh my original idea was to make two
separate videos today, one for the stock
market, well, the S&P
and commodities like gold and then the
Forex
market and then a different video for
Bitcoin, but to be honest Bitcoin is not
really giving us much, okay? So I
thought, well, I might as well just put
it at the end of this video.
Um so anyway, guys, thank you so much
for watching
and I'll see you soon.